- Do you suddenly have a lot of time on your hands?
THEN COME ON DOWN TO Camp Loseabigamo.
Please come get me.
- Little Truss, boo hoo.
- CAMP LOSEABIGAMO, HAVE YOU HEARD THE NEWS?
THAT’S RIGHT, SPORTS FANS,
IT’S ACTUALLY COOL TO LOSE.
- [Together:] WE’RRRREEE LOSERS!
- With activities such as...
- WHERE THE F--K IS THE FLAG?!?!
- MAKE ME FLY, KYLER!
- Do you guys think we’ll ever be too old
to play games all day?
- I made a friendship bracelet.
- We've got the lead, just keep spinning, baby!
- They have talent, they're just using it weird.
- I’m homesick for the playoffs.
- US TOOOO…
- I’ll be your friend…
- LOOK, I MAY BE COVERED IN GADDUMB GLITTER
BUT AT LEAST I FLUFFIN' TRY.
- So, I turn the corner and what do I see?
It's a team that's solid on defense...
AND OFFENSE.
- Kittle, taste the pain, bro!
- [Together:] AHHHHHH!
- Hey, lights off!
- I WANT TO BE UNDER THE LIGHTS A
LITTLE LONGER.
- Or spend all your time sadly staring at the
championship camp across the lake.
- WAH, you're too big, Derrick!
- CAMP FRIENDS AREN’T REAL FRIENDS.
- TRACTORCITO!